I just want to show you one other thing
because look I'm giving him credit where
credit is due the good stuff at the
beginning then he said something that it
was fairly bananas which is that the
Deep state is trying to get him
my gut instinct is that I will be the
nominee and in a position to win this in
a landslide versus Biden and they will
not let Biden run against me
so I believe that if I am the nominee
they will not let Biden run it is why
they're holding in the back pocket the
documents case against Biden it is why
they're holding in the back pocket
everything else that you're wondering
why they're not charging or bringing now
it's not a Democrat or Republican thing
it's a managerial class deep State
bureaucratic class versus elected
official puppets what he just said there
was that if he is the nominee
that the Deep state will not allow Biden
to run now I do think the Deep state
does all kinds of crazy things I think
there is a huge issue if it is not Trump
because if it is say vivec or Ron
DeSantis or Nikki or anyone that is
younger and more competent the
juxtaposition of that old
dementium-ridden man versus these young
people will be too much the chasm will
be too wide the Democrats won't know
what to do with it but the idea that
he's saying he's saying it basically as
fact the Deep state is holding it in
their pocket that they will get rid of
Biden if it is me like that's like
that's Trump level Gish gallop dish
Gallop when you lie so brazenly that
nobody knows what to do with it so they
kind of let you have it that is
basically uh where he is at with that so
anyway I'm trying to give you the good
and the bad I hopefully did that in in
as honest away as possible
[Music]